this week we've got nerd grandpa
Mulan casting and rain story hero
limestone [ __ ] happened to my kazoo I
wonder what the controversy about the
Milan casting is gonna be sure wonder
you'll never guess it really you'll
never call it Johansson's play Milan or
some [ __ ] you guessed it ha I'll be
fighting if Hollywood plays this joke
where every time there's a female agent
role they use Scarlett Johansson or
Matilda tildes with it Tulse one till
the Swinton yeah be good oh yeah she did
please you know who could probably play
an Asian better than Asian is Meryl
Streep
oh yeah you know she could play anything
she [ __ ] kills it guaranteed I love
every movie she's in high bar first
story there's this grandpa
he has a lucky seven two years old from
China Oh No Taiwan sorry Taiwan yeah
don't tell them that they'll get angry
don't get [ __ ] pissed for no reason
you love in smartphones to play pokemon
go oh why why does that look like future
Michael he does does yeah you're in his
pocket and then so he carries all these
oh they're right here wait is it like
strapped to his belt or some [ __ ] so he
could walk and do this way holy what's
on his bicycle it's all to one account
fun he's fun yeah I want to be that yeah
I want to kick it with bag full of
battery packs where you charges are they
all iPhones nothing above all the genius
how is he not beat the game in like five
days no so he's he is playing so he's
dumb day he just has a lot of fun he's
he likes meeting new people within all
of the phones be on the same level
though cuz it's only the pokemons that
are in that area it's not like different
phones get different pokemons so I feel
like they'd all be if it doesn't
technically make sense you understand
what's your name
oh you know what you might be doing I
want to give him some tips you might be
selling so he gets him up to a certain
level and selling them or he could just
be having a really fun time if he likes
it that much yeah he really does think
he's saying that he this he feels like
this is keeping him but he's old and
he's retired maybe he's just having fun
busy retired you just made that up but
that's what we're all doing but you
can't do it yeah I can't play okay don't
play please playing this game prevents
him from having Alzheimer's and he likes
to make friends with other players so he
likes which is true if you don't use
your brain that's how it goes yeah so
then he also likes have you guys ever
played Pokemon good I've never played
this more Sauvage it's option where you
can lure and so like yeah bring Oh to
that area if you you activate a lure and
that's cool but he does that all the
time it's pretty funny when you're when
the game first came out like people
would swarm different areas like and
everyone's what their phones up but
everyone wanted to pretend like they're
out playing Pokemon God yeah great first
came out oh and we were you would park
in certain areas yeah like a bunch of
you will be parked there yeah they're
all acting like do not playing Pokemon
go in their car it's [ __ ] great we
used to go on hold dates where we would
go around the town yeah you'd play yeah
played for like three days yeah for like
three day and then the and then the
tracker thing broke and then we're like
[ __ ] this games he sucks I don't see
anyone playing it anymore
I don't either I've seen people on and
off playing it they had a tracker where
if you if you saw like that a pokémon's
was in your area you keep like go chase
that pokey man's right and then when you
get that pac-man's you can catch him but
you had but you knew who you're after
but now it's just all randomized so you
can't get the pic of immens anymore it's
so annoying yeah do people used to just
like announce it to like if you're
looking for [ __ ] charm and
to do this [ __ ] yeah like Pokemon go
Pokemon headhunters yeah yeah they'll be
like there's a [ __ ] rare Bulbasaur
here or whatever and you can yeah
they're not rare I mean holy [ __ ] good
magic card like the water pokemon were
near the water and like the fire was you
know they're in different areas near
fire California wildfires actually is
not a terrible idea I guess it is though
because people go there yeah then maybe
they can help
oh that's pretty good that's all right
you wanna bring buckets yeah yes oh you
said that I'm just gonna be in the
middle of the flagger doing this yeah
it's true
well the flexion flames are all the way
you go near electric power plants you
can get a Pikachu maybe you two was
always at a Roma cafe
whenever I rolled my walks in the
morning there would always be a Pikachu
in the same spot that's true and now
people can find where we live and kill
us I don't live there anymore where do
you live now we we move - oh yeah so
this guy boy says that this hobby is
costing him about $1,500 a month
oh [ __ ] because he's buying all the
lures and the pokeballs and stuff but
it's all a so right now he has 11 phones
but sometimes he only uses nine of them
because those those are the ones they
count that are on level 30 or higher and
then he says that he eventually wants to
have 15 he doesn't even need to have
service on all the phones - and you just
have like one pocket Wi-Fi thing and
connect them ah ah ah ah
that's what I do grandpa knows how to
party yeah when I go to other countries
that's my travel hack I just get a
pocket Wi-Fi at the airport BAM mmm but
you can only contact other iphones
unless you use a skype you can use their
phone you could use the fiber or
whatever is called that's a that's a
sexual app for having sex with strangers
oh no we used it in Europe
for our next story Jimmy Wong was casted
in Mulan Oh
ready Freddie Wong's little brother yeah
is he playing Mulan odo yeah
congratulations
oh you know him I don't Freddie I don't
I've met him a couple times but I don't
really know know him I'm gonna cast it
of course is the past tense of haven't
asked him what did I say don't dog her
damn he's doing I just get so much as
you Jaden fused how I love you TIFF I do
it out of love you feel every day now I
know what you play a man crazy
thank you Tim the correct term is casted
thank you casted it all right so yeah
more people that have been casted so
this guy that's where I used to Molly
and speak to him okay looks like the
villain duo more you've got to be
developed he looks like he could be on
Milan like [ __ ] in Gran Torino yeah he
was oh yeah he looks so familiar
oh that's where I saw that's a long name
more so they were both Jimmy Wong and
Dora
ma were casted as Ling in PO oh cool
were they the comedic relief there were
the comedic guys right the guys that
were the Joker's now those are like
little dragon guys right I forgot they
were part of Milan's crew yeah the funny
guys yeah what a skinny one yes no no
one's trying to take a bath and
wondering why I like Mulan doesn't to
take a bath with them oh she's gonna get
me and move on of course his plate I
just watched it like two two months it's
lon of course is played by mary
elizabeth winstead and i'm really
Mulan's gonna be Scott no villain is you
fake new is Lucy Liu in the movie and
bailing
sorry from singing room is she like a
Hong Kong star a Taiwan star or
something she kind of looks like um she
doesn't look American at all she kind of
looks like Megan Lee singer we met her
she's a singer oh yeah
she's American Chinese so what's the
controversy behind it no controversy is
just like no he was saying it easing
controversy I think for us it's like hey
this is cool cast full of like YouTube
peoples and stuff like actual in actual
Asians he doesn't know thank God why
what's the Aladdin controversy well the
Aladdin was was they said they couldn't
find any middle-eastern dyes to play a
lot all right there's a hella Middle
Eastern said they couldn't find anybody
so be he's Indian right that's it or
whatever it is al added in the Arabian
no they're saying that according to
Aladdin's like first story they don't
really specify where exactly it comes
from is just somewhere in that middle is
the world
Agrabah yeah that's what he comes from
now that's true well they have the song
Arabian Nights so I assume there's
somewhere like Saudi Arabia oh I don't
think they have a ribbon it's in Aladdin
I think that was it's just the song I
think the Disney live-action suit sucks
dick frankly better
yeah like the car dudes wait Jungle Book
I was like oh really
but it's just a direct copy it's almost
like Tracy that's what I love it I love
that it's a direct copy because then I
get to see what it looks like in real
life just like with Beauty and the Beast
- they were doing the whole scenes just
like that animated I heard you T and the
Beast wasn't that's more love dick it's
[ __ ] tracing we don't like jungle
book that was pretty cool uh I'm with
him well maybe because I never watched
original jungle you'd rather see an
original yeah like let me just see the
original and that already I already made
up my mind about that one and I'd like
him to have good memories attached and
then to do the exact same thing but in
it ruins it yeah it's made it real you
don't you
it's not a real story it is not cute
yeah you guys don't like watch me you
guys don't like watching the same thing
in a different format like you wouldn't
watch fast and furious are nice of
course I would watch that what are you
talking about farce amazing right no
this is different because there's Disney
on Ice and we will watch that nicest
waiver [ __ ]
yeah but then ice is not a direct cop
carbon right watching ice skaters do
something cool yeah but wearing you know
wife beaters yeah Vin Diesel on ice I
would love to watch that he's so cool in
real life like they look real light
you're not wrong you're right yeah
you're right you're allowed to have that
app in Jurassic Park on I can you
imagine Jurassic Park on my hands I want
to see a [ __ ] velociraptor do a
triple axel yeah why don't they do that
be so sick you're not creative like we
have in Garden State where Natalie
Portman's character is like a dinosaur
on ice and she does this like whole I
remember that part I just remember the
night where she's sitting then there
were like [ __ ] stone and in the night
these roommate I just remember them
shouting shouting into the junkyard
about how hard their lives are they
didn't shout that yes they did just
scream yeah they did was it was about
that she's about really letting go cuz a
main character was so like in his head
all the time I thought I was funny
remember you're twisting the narrative
I'm not to listen it it was not yelling
by heart didn't [ __ ] zach braff like
cutie zach braff like wearing his
wallpaper shirts match screen going like
my life's hard my messenger bags too
heavy No
his mom died and killed herself look his
mom killed him herself and then him and
his dad's don't have a good relationship
I thought he I thought he was sad
because Nicole he lost his ear buds and
he just bought all my favorite part is
when they were at the light glory hole
or whatever or not the court hold there
was like a boy there was a peepshow
there different a little bit different
Nikki yeah I'm sorry the guy was like
some titties today I said who saw some
titties today and then Natalie Portman I
like that move yeah that's a great movie
what movie are we talking apart in space
say everyone should watch a sponsored by
Garden State yeah I love the soundtrack
anyone's ever read 2003 yep
so Mulan they're saying that it will be
released March 27 2029 2020 very soon I
know that this is you all it takes it's
just medicine I didn't know that it took
Asian actors outlawed on learning lines
that's all that's true Bart you talk a
lot of [ __ ] now Bart but we'll see how
you doin zombies well you better do the
karate stuff first and I told you I told
you I'm getting that actor double I'm
doing the stunts by myself but I'm gonna
do actor double all right for our last
story this woman in West Virginia she
returned a shopping cart in the middle
of some crazy-ass rain and wind and she
was honored by Walmart what a nice lady
good for her Oh oh my [ __ ] look at stop
signs you know chill yes that's mine I
should just [ __ ] leave it at your
trunk
Wow it's a hurricane
oh my god she's the button she's like
been there done that been there done
that I'm surprised the [ __ ] cart
didn't blow back at her eyes I'm
surprised the [ __ ] sideways boat
doesn't hit her who's recording her - I
think an employee there's someone that's
in their own car I think wow I love that
woman I want to hug her
yeah she's 70 years old oh she's a
[ __ ] us how was she honored by walnut
mark they gave her a couple new no she
they gave her a trophy for the most epic
cart return and she was awarded a year
supply of grocery yeah grocery pickup so
she will never have to be that's pretty
dope and then some groceries
what's grocery pick up so like she
doesn't have to go to Walmart they just
deliver it to her house service cuz they
realize that you don't want to go to
Walmart so they provide a service
service you don't the out of your car
but you stuff the goat along so you
order it online and then you drive up
and if they drop it off yeah the
commercials are great like we know you
don't want to walk into Walmart so we
figured it out for it it's really good
it's good sometimes I like to walk into
Walmart yeah I bet you're like this is
the only time I get away from my husband
damn it huh what do you know the worst
thing about Walmart is the checkout line
that's it in there self checkout no the
worst thing about it it takes a long
time we're thing about CVS is the
checkout line your privilege your
privilege going to Walmart and
complaining about the checkout line
because at CVS the checkout line is like
waiting for Space Mountain and there's
one employee there's one employee oh you
know why they look so [ __ ] sad and
there's a line of people out the door
it's like it's Black Friday you it's
it's cuz I go to Walmart I like to a.m.
so then there's only like one register
open totally the people of Walmart you
are the people of Walmart
I've only been to Walmart in Hawaii that
was nice yeah oh you didn't go with this
double a huge souvenir section
yeah but then no matter where you are in
America people are warm are the same not
only America around the world that's
true
oh they do why no they have one in
Mexico at least I know I gotta check it
out cuz I never I never been since the
invention of the automobile in the boat
white trash has gone worldwide yep
don't you know it's like it's like
trashes the state's our export exactly
trash is the same no matter where you
are in the world they like the same kind
of clothes they get the same kind of
body shape they get the same color even
in China Argentina Botswana I bet you in
the Chinese Walmart there's a fat
Chinese do with a cutoff t-shirt and
some basketball shorts Japan there's in
a Walmart in Japan India there's Ana
Walmart in India there's a fat Indian
dude with a cutoff t-shirt in Japan -
cutoff t-shirt basketball shorts you're
gonna see that [ __ ] China they just take
the they just make the stuff for Walmart
and then they just take it over there
they walk it across the mall Mart
there's another store called Walmart oh
yeah knock off a discount Walmart and
Costco Costco just when they make a
little bit more money right
like you make a little bit more money
will you charge a membership and now
will they right so now you now you get
to go to Costco and then it's always no
Sam's Club no Sam's Clubs another one
well Costco's like where people walk
around and then they're just a little
bit better like very little bit better
and they all wait and all you do at
Costco is go like what a better deal no
there's so many times at Costco I would
always sneak in with a family you just
walk in with them yeah no I go sample of
all the food and then I will you know
yeah that's true I wear sunglasses
pretty good you blend in with the black
hair
yeah Costco is like pretty dope except
when you have to buy stuff like in the
checkout line again instacart dude
that's my jam you use go see yeah yeah
we're trying to get to use that at
Ralph's is it the instacart thing where
you left oh no no no no oh I mean maybe
you could do that
no but instacart like it works with
grocery stores and stores near you so
Costco stores near you yeah all the
words here you
and I feel better to send advertising
just to control your brain and spit it
out of your mouth only the stores around
your area oh yeah so anything that's
around you and your your area then it
pops up and then so I have Costco
Albertsons or whatever and then I just
go to Costco and then I could shop from
Costco and then I get like the Kirkland
water and whatever I want from coffee
you or on the screen or so liver to your
plate yep and then you schedule a next
little store near you and then whenever
you schedule it these are dropping off
huh I never entered cost to pay extra
you don't like to just walk around I
like to walk around the store and like
see me do with my hands behind my back
they get you and then they slow you you
look like that that is funny game I'm
the mom and the child that targets so
I'm the channel I put everything in the
cart and then I might put it back put it
I mean it I'll put it back we already
have pill you're [ __ ] okay just get
one okay you have one if I don't shop
with Jess it's all over but then if Jess
is hungry then we're both [ __ ] up oh
[ __ ] yes she knows how to gauge like
what we're gonna eat and what we're not
pretty well she's really good at I got
eating clean you mean they're like
healthy I mean like if things are just
gonna sit in the cover forever you're
also pretty ridiculous though cuz you're
like I got eczema but I still want this
milk and I want this ice cream and I
want this and she's like no shut the
[ __ ] up all right mom put it back that's
how he is I just killed him oh it's easy
though it's like though you want to have
a bad time so he goes like he goes oh
can i order nachos I'm like yeah you can
order whatever you want if you don't
want to lose like if you want to stay
fast won't stay fam be fat boy
that doesn't work on me I'm like that's
true no it gets him that's cuz I'm a
guilty as Catholic boy
[Music]